let's cast our mind back to last week
i gave you this exact set of data i
wonder if you actually remember looking
at it it's a classic situation with data
in terms of heights of students you
might recall i actually got you i think
it was on the wednesday to have a look
back at this set of data because there
was a particular feature in this set of
data that's not obvious until you start
to look at the numbers closely does
anyone remember
what's the feature in this set of data
that was important started with an m
sort of
or a b depending on the way you think
about it um we looked at modality do you
remember that this idea of some sets of
data have one or more like very common
scores and we call that the modality of
the scores this has a particular
modality it's bimodal right and so if
you had a look i mean i'll just
highlight it for you right
you've got
the mode here and then the mode here
they're not exactly the same 31 but they
don't need to be for the clear peaks to
be observable if you say for example
graphed the data right
now this is important to know because we
said look if it's bimodal something like
the mean
or the standard deviation is much less
meaningful because get it meaningful um
because the mean is like in the middle
here it doesn't represent any group of
people at all right at least in this
particular set of data now the key thing
that i wanted to remind you of as you
had a look at this was that even though
there are so many numbers numbers here
there's really just and this is worth
actually jotting down because it's going
to be a point of contrast there is
really just a single
variable this is single variable data
and that's why
when we went to our calculators and
we're doing the calculation on this
you may recall the buttons that we
pressed we ended up pressing that one
that said
one var single variable right now i
promised that we would go past single
variable even though you've got like all
of these complicated things really it's
just the height that is changing that is
the one quantity that we're interested
in we're now moving into this second sub
topic for those of you keeping track at
home in the syllabus it's m a
s 2.2 mathematics advanced statistics
where in this section here we're going
to now look at here's the the actual
heading for you
by variant data now
like the name suggests right it's a
pretty simple idea instead of having
just a single variable we're interested
in
to what is a variable after all
it's just a quantity that changes right
so by various data all it means is two
quantities that change it's just so
important that when you're throwing
around
flinging terminology like this around
you understand there's a simple idea
underneath it and in this case it's just
like there's two things i want to often
compare what if i wanted to compare not
just height but say age in this
particular example it'd be less
meaningful because everyone's roughly
the same age in year 12 but maybe if i
broadened out to the entire school i now
have two data points that are worth
comparing to each other does that make
sense
okay
so the way to make sense of this is to
have a think about some actual data and
we're going to do this all together and
i thought what i would do is bring out a
bit of personal data for you this is a
personal piece of bivariate data that i
plotted this morning
and before we talk about what it is i
just want you to take note of what's not
there okay
there's no
labels on the axes ah there is a scale
but there are no units right so over on
the left here you're like
4.5.6
4.5 or 4.6
what right
that by the way tells you something
important you know when we had a look at
single variable data
you would have a vertical axis that
almost always was in whole numbers why
is that
i don't have whole numbers here why do
we usually have whole numbers on our
single and our vertical axis any
suggestions
should we go back
have a look at this data set again
what would the
horizontal axis have been in this case
the horizontal axis in this case would
probably be
height it's it's the single variable
right but the vertical axis is almost
always in single variable data this
over here
it's the frequency it's how many of
these things there are you're counting
them therefore you get whole numbers
make sense okay you're not going to have
31.5 people who are in that 165 to 169
range so when you have a look here
clearly you're not in kansas anymore
yeah you are no longer counting a thing
there is some measurement happening but
it's not being counted
okay does anyone want to have a guess
just a wild tab in the dark what this
data set actually means like i said my
clue was it's personal to me
any guesses
say that again michael numerical
continues numerical oh okay so we're
having a look at the data type this is
numerical and yes it is continuous
because you can see these um you've got
all these different ranges it's not
discrete like we talked about before but
the question i was really asking was
what does this data signify
like what's its meaning to me and the
answer is it's about
running
so i like to run it took me a long time
like when i was your age i was kind of
obsessed with like my friends who were
popular were like strong and muscular
and in case you had not worked out
already i am neither strong nor muscular
it took me a long time to realize you
know what distance running is your thing
that's that's what you can actually do
so these are
runs that i have done based on their
distance okay uh i generally run like my
shorter runs at six kilometers because
that's how long of a cross-country i did
when i was in u12 so that's my benchmark
and then i've been trying to work toward
you might be able to work out i mean i
don't know if you can quite see that
scale over there there's a number just
above 20. would anyone like to hazard a
guess what that number is it's
significant to anyone who knows about
running yeah go ahead
it's a half marathon so 21.1 kilometers
because a real marathon is 42.2 i'm
nowhere close to that by the way so this
is what i'm trying to do
and you can see i have this measure of
how fast i've run on the vertical axis
so let's look at this closely
so these are not lengths of time these
are not durations
this is how fast this is a measure of
how fast i'm going right now the
particular pace i've got is just from
the app that keeps track right so this
is how many minutes it takes me to run a
single kilometer on the basis of these
particular runs that i've done so just
have a look
uh four point three minutes
that's like four minutes and
uh i don't know like 20 seconds ish
right that's the very fastest i can run
in fact if i'm memory service i think
it's four minutes 19 and then up here
that's something like that's close to
five minutes right like four minutes 57
58 something like that okay
now these are the two
variables right pace
and kilometers
underneath this this is the first
important thing you need to draw down
underneath your heading of bivariate
data
because we are not just looking a single
variable and how often or how frequently
occurs
what we have is two kinds of variable
generally speaking and this is language
you've heard before but i just want to
formalize it now is the right time
generally speaking one of them will be
what we call independent and the other
one will be
dependent which is exactly what it
sounds like there is some relationship
between these two things and the
dependent variable changes
in response to
the independent variable let me say that
one more time right
when you have a look at your two
variables you can tell which one is
independent which one is dependent based
on which one of them
changes in response
to the other okay there's one that's
kind of like free you can make it
whatever you like and then the other one
just kind of like follows suit depending
on that depending on the independent
variable so let's have a look at this
data set that i just gave you
right now this one's a tricky one and i
i like it because actually we can have a
discussion about it
which do you think is the independent
variable and which would you think is
the dependent variable now just put your
hands down for something i'm actually
going to get you to vote for a minute
and i'm just going to say right out the
gate
there's no wrong answer to this so long
as you have a reason for it okay